fidelity they have pushed for a bitcoin
etf
in a secret meeting with the sec right
out of the gate here's the deal i don't
like the fact that people are calling it
a secret meeting it's not a secret
meeting the sec cftc et cetera other
regulators meet all the time with market
participants they openly say hey we
would like to talk to you please come
and talk to us about things that you're
concerned about or things that you want
to discuss and so fidelity which is one
of the largest asset managers in the
world had a meeting over zoom with the
sec there's nothing secret about it
there's nothing in my opinion that's
shady about it etc during the meeting
fidelity urged the sec again urge makes
it seem like they were like pounding the
table definitely talked to the sec to
approve its bitcoin exchange traded fund
in a private meeting of course every
meeting is private between an asset
manager and the sec and so uh there's
several firms all have submitted these
applications they're trying to go ahead
and get bitcoin etfs approved
and fidelity basically is making the
argument that uh there is a very very
deep investor appetite for uh
cryptocurrencies virtual currencies uh
two is that there's been incredible
growth of bitcoin adoption and so
there's literally tens of millions of
people around the world that hold
bitcoin and then lastly is um that there
are tons of other funds like this both
etfs and etps in other countries so how
is it that canada or other countries
have these funds but we here in the
united states do not and so fidelity is
filed for a bitcoin uh etp um which is
called the wise origin bitcoin trust in
march of 2021 and more than 20 other
similar applications from other firms
have been made as well and then fidelity
is planning to increase its crypto asset
employee numbers by up to 70 percent by
the end of the year according to
bloomberg we have two quotes one is from
nicole abbott uh federally spokeswoman
she said an increasingly wide range of
investors seeking access to bitcoin has
underscored the market need for more
diversified set of products offering
exposure to digital assets to match
demand and then we have another one from
fidelity i think this is just a letter
they wrote we believe bitcoin features
based products are not necessary interim
step before bitcoin etp firms should be
able to meet investor demand for direct
exposure to bitcoin through the 33 act
1933 act bitcoin etps because the
bitcoin market has matured and can
support them
i generally think that a bitcoin etf
obviously is going to get approved the
united states at some point
this year seems unlikely but we will see
but in the next two years or so i could
easily see a bitcoin etf being approved
on top of that i think that we
drastically underestimate the importance
of an etf-like structure we have
grayscale's uh gbtc product we have
bitwise's bitw product we also have
companies that hold a lot of bitcoin
like microstrategy etc and when you
start to look at this you can go back
and you can look at past assets when the
etf gets approved there are some asset
management firms that can't buy the
trust the gbtc trust
because it trades at a premium or at a
discount to nav and so there's
restrictions around also some people are
not going to go buy micro strategy stock
and say oh it's good enough indirect
exposure to bitcoin they're going to
wait for the etf so once that etf gets
approved i think that there is likely
going to be a surge in demand the beauty
of bitcoin is if you have a fixed supply
asset and demand increases price is
likely to drastically increase quickly
so what do we think the odds of a
bitcoin etf being approved is uh let's
say in the next 18 to 24 months 18 to
24.
i feel like that's probably pretty
likely if you said six months i wouldn't
be as confident but 18 to 24. i mean
they've been working on this for two or
three years now right
oh of course infidelity is like the
safest person you could do it with why
do you say that it's interesting you say
that because you don't spend all day
like thinking about what is what is the
name of the woman who was at the head of
the crypto division at fidelity she was
driving the change
uh
wait you mean the entire fidelity
abigail johnson abigail johnson yeah
she's the head of all the fidelity oh
all of fidelity that's right that's
right yeah yeah she has been very crypto
forward uh for years now and i think
that fidelity is something that you
think about like hey i use it my
grandmother uses it it's safe and so are
you saying that that's a big part of why
they are likely to be part of the
approval yes
so my big thing on the bitcoin etf is i
don't think they're gonna pick one
player they're not just saying okay
fidelity you get the etf approval nobody
else does like the regulators aren't in
the business of king making instead what
they're likely to do again no promise
but likely is that the regulators are
going to say okay uh fidelity bitwise
sky bridge uh grayscale and whoever else
all of you get approved at the same time
we approve six of you go and let the
market figure out who gets the assets
and who doesn't to me that is uh one
much more fair and then also two is the
competition ends up holding fees lower
and really driving kind of innovation
and uh and adoption in the market it
would be wild to me if we saw them just
say hey uh we're only going to pick one
and the regulator's got to choose who
the winner i don't think they're really
debating um the players at all right
they a lot of big institutions sky
bridge fidelity all these places have
applied for these um and very
trustworthy institutions in the space i
think they're more obviously just
looking at bitcoin ets and etps in
general
um and then when they make that decision
they're going to go ahead and approve a
bunch of them at the same time or at
least a week or a month kind of lag in
the next 18 to 24 months i 100 see them
approving one um or proving a few i
would say but in the in like joe said in
the next six months it's probably up in
the air a little bit um as they work
through it but yeah they've been working
on this forever i mean eventually we're
gonna start lagging behind other
countries and other other markets
because we don't have this available to
people who want access to it yeah and i
think etfs are like they're generally
seen as a a safer investment vehicle
depending on kind of what people are
looking for so
not only is it a matter of time but it's
in the best interest of kind of the
organizations that are involved to get
something worked out and ironed out but
yeah i agree i don't think that uh
they're gonna king make someone i think
that it only makes sense to uh put
everyone on a level playing field and i
think that's what's really taking so
long is saying hey look we want to do
five six seven of these at a time uh we
don't want to just give kind of a first
mover advantage to uh fidelity or gray
scale or whoever it ends up being and
say hey look you're the winner here uh
everyone go you know pump assets into
their their fund and stuff like that i
think it's more about uh putting
everyone on a level playing field and
saying hey we approved five or six of
these uh now go fight it out provide the
best product uh compressed fees down to
zero et cetera and i think uh what we'll
see is it's gonna bring in drastic more
drastically more demand for the space uh
as people go figure out that these are
kind of safer and more uh maybe
diversified or whatever vehicles that
you can invest in the space in i'll be
interested to see if um if and when
fidelity gets approved that uh if they
allow access from retirement accounts
because such a big retirement
organization on a bunch of corporations
have their retirement accounts through
fidelity if they access that capital and
let that go into the etf that would
obviously um bring a lot of money into
the space the uh most important part of
the etf conversation
to me is once it gets approved is let's
look at a gold when the etf got approved
and gold have you guys ever seen this
chart this is wild so
right there is the first gold etf that
launched and look at the price of gold
right after the etfs just massive influx
of demand and it just exploded so you
can see for you know almost 20 years
before there was just kind of flat price
movement right there there's a little
bit of fluctuation but not really and
then all of a sudden they went from sub
500 it's like 200 gold all the way up to
eventually in 2011 it peaked around uh
you know like 1800 bucks or so and so
when you see something like this now in
there in 2008 2009 uh and in 2010 there
was also the global financial crisis so
uh there's a lot of monetary stimulus
etc that forced people into gold but you
can see from 2000 to 2003 up until that
financial crash there was still pretty
significant uh increase in um
in demand and price we laughing it well
it's also over
over a six
six seven year period right so but my
point is it flowed in immediately no but
that's my point is once you once you
create the etf and you open up the
opportunity for people to come in then
what ends up happening is you get
increased demand and it's not just a
one-time thing it's a persistent
increase in demand and so gold is
already somewhat scarce asset if you
look at something like bitcoin which is
more scarce it ends up being really
really powerful i want these to get
approved
i'll be very clear about that i want
them to get approved like now yeah but
even if you look at the chart before the
global financial crisis it clearly had
an impact on uh the overvalue of gold
because it trended in that kind of
range for
uh two decades prior and then for the
three to four years after that why is
that because because the etf uh opens up
people access to without having to hold
gold itself yeah it opens up a wider
range of potential investors
i think that the etf gets approved i
don't think it's this year if it gets
approved this year plus what we're
seeing in the on-chain metrics
yeah do that dance again john
yeah that's exactly what will be
happening everyone that watches the show
be dancing across the across the living
room what's up guys bang bang thanks so
much for watching the best business show
today if we're gonna be the best
business show we obviously need the best
partner that's why the exclusive sponsor
the best business show is sofi they're
an all-in-one platform that allows you
to invest in all kinds of different
assets including stocks etfs crypto ipos
and they even have an automated
investing function if that's your thing
so before we start getting after it
again make sure that you go download
sofi you get an invest account and when
you make your first crypto trade
regardless of what you buy they'll give
you 10 in bitcoin for free it's that
simple head on over to sofi.com to get
started today thanks so much for
watching and i hope you come back and
watch more the best business show
tomorrow
[Music]